اداره شركه تويتر لربما هي وظيفه الاحلام
لكن بعد الكوارث التي تعاقبت على الشركه
بعد استحواذ الى الماسك عليها باتت وظيفه
الكوابيس بعد نتيجه استطلاع الراي الذي
نشره ماسك والتي ادت الى انسحابه من اداره
الشركه شكل الملياردير الامريكي فريقا
للحفاظ على تشغيل تويتر دون تسميه رئيسا
تنفيذيه جديد مؤكدا انه سيظل في المنصب
حتى ايجاد ذلك الرئيس
حل الخيوط الشائكه التي عقدها ماسك منذ
توليه
المعلمين والاشكلات الناجمه عن اغلاق
حسابات بعض الصحفيين
[موسيقى]
بمجرد ان يجد شخصا يتولى المنصب
عن اداره تويتر
[موسيقى]
الامريكي الذي لمعت في راسه فكره شراء
تويتر بين ليله وضحاها ليتخلى عن ادارتها
باستطلاع راي وما بين الفكرتين قرارات
قلبت الشركه الكبيره راسا على عقب لتحتز
الاوضاع الماليه لها وتؤثر على سمعتها
منصه تضمن حريه التعبير وعمر العربيه
[موسيقى]